that's president Trump's push to reshape
the Supreme Court for decades it's going
to head now to Capitol Hill this morning
where his new nominee will meet with
Republican leaders the president called
Brett Cavanaugh's credentials impeccable
and unsurpassed when he announced the
nomination in a prime time TV address
last night
he also said Cavanaugh has a proven
commitment to equal justice supporters
of abortion rights protested against the
pic last night outside the Supreme Court
Jan Crawford is on Capitol Hill with the
look at the nominees and the next steps
Jan good morning well good morning so
judge Cavanaugh is going to be escorted
by vice president pence when they come
here later this morning he is 53 years
old he is a former law clerk for Justice
Kennedy and he's considered a
conservative intellectual powerhouse and
his nomination could give Republicans a
chance to change the direction of the
court for years to come this is the most
important decision a president will make
in a prime time address Monday President
Trump introduced Judge Brett Kavanaugh
to the nation he is considered a judges
judge a true thought leader among his
peers highly regarded on the federal
appeals court Cavanaugh has a clear
conservative judicial philosophy a judge
must be independent and must interpret
the law not make the law he was a
favorite of the conservative legal
establishment with his elite academic
credentials but with a regular guy
persona who loves basketball and coaches
his young daughters teams
Margaret loves sports and she loves to
read
Liza loves sports
and she loves to talk
but now Cavanaugh must face Capitol Hill
where he'll find some old opponents many
of us have deep concerns about this
nominee during his contentious 2006
confirmation hearing Democrats targeted
his record on President Bush's legal
team in the 2000 election recount and
the Kenneth Starr investigation that led
to President Clinton's impeachment
impeachment and and then conviction
taken to account more than just the
facts
Cavanaugh's past positions on
presidential power may also become a
focus as Special Counsel Robert Muller's
on going Russia investigation hangs over
the presidency in a 2009 article
Cavanaugh argued we should not burden a
sitting president with civil suits
Criminal Investigations or criminal
prosecution that if the president does
something dastardly the impeachment
process is available now Democrats
already are signaling they're going to
make this fight about the future of
abortion and you know the issue though
is that the Republicans kind of have
this narrow majority in the Senate so
there's very little that Democrats can
do to block him I mean they squandered
the use of the filibuster trying to
block justice gore shuts but let me tell
you they are still going to try to
hammer him every chance that they get
Norah
Jan thank you so much